new york governor andrew cuomo says he
won't resign over sexual harassment
claims made by three women
but cuomo did apologize yesterday for
making anyone feel uncomfortable it was
his first public appearance
since these allegations surfaced the
governor promised to cooperate with the
state attorney general's investigation
into all of this
and our national correspondent rica
duncan is in albany new york with
reaction from cuomo's
fellow democrats it's a bipartisan issue
at this point eureka good morning to you
good morning there are some democrats
within cuomo's party that want him to
step aside
but most leaders within his party are
saying the same as cuomo
wait until the investigation has been
completed
i asked the people of this state
to wait for the facts from the attorney
general's
report before forming an opinion
that seems to be exactly what most
democratic party leaders in new york are
doing
including the state senators i think
overwhelmingly there's
a sense that we should be fair about
this new york state democratic chair jay
jacobs says
a lot will depend on the outcome of the
investigation
we don't want to look back at it at some
time in the distant future and
think that maybe we rushed this
since the first allegations of sexual
harassment came to light
the calls for the governor's resignation
have grown
some 20 democrats are now calling for
him to step down
but with leadership taking a
wait-and-see approach the governor
is holding on i'm not going to resign
though in his first public appearance
since the allegations he did apologize
i now understand that i
acted in a way that made
people feel uncomfortable it was
unintentional and i truly and deeply
apologize for it i am
embarrassed by it he doesn't get a pass
deborah katz represents former aide
charlotte bennett who claims the
governor asked her questions about her
sex life
that's inappropriate to derail her
career katz also slammed the governor's
explanation for this picture of him with
anna ruck
who says cuomo tried to kiss her i
never touched anyone
inappropriately you can go find hundreds
of pictures of me
kissing people men women it is my usual
and customary way of greeting that
picture
is exhibit a that he did the very thing
that today
he denied in a press conference this is
far more
significant than the governor is
embarrassed he engaged in unlawful
sexual harassment
and he needs to acknowledge that
meanwhile here in albany lawmakers are
working to strip the governor of his
covet emergency powers what does that
mean
essentially the governor would have to
consult with the legislature before
making any
pandemic related decisions
jerica thank you